понад півмільйона педагогічних
працівників продовжують навчати дітей в
дитячих садочках школах і закладах
позашкілля у воєнний стан очно онлайн
дистанційно Під звуки повітряних тривог
у бомбосховищах за різних умов
українські діти продовжують вчитися Та
додалася ще одна проблема відключення
світла через атаки російських окупантів
у міносвіти рішення є застосунок вивчаю
Не чекаю який дозволяє навіть за
відсутності інтернету учням початкових
класів опановувати основні е-е
основний контент до того ж працюватиме
електронна бібліотека з майже понад
тисячі трьохсотень підручників для
школярів докладніше про складний
освітній процес поговоримо з Сергієм
шкарлутом міністром освіти і науки
України він зараз доєднується до нашої
ефіру п міністр Я вас вітаю Слава
Україні
Героям слава Доброго ранку і дякую за
сестрою
світу пане міністр попри постійні
загрози і от удари та перебої з
комунікаціями освітні процес в Україні
триває оновлювальний опалювальний сезон
буде складним чи вдасться обігріти
навчальні заклади і Які нестандартні
рішення якщо вони вводяться то все-таки
доводиться ухвалювати
Я дякую за запитання адже в умовах
постійних ефект російських Федерації і
саме на об'єкти критичної інфраструктури
дійсно це постає проблема в опалюванні
вони в енергозабезпечені але хочу
зазначити що уряд Дениса шмигеля завжди
ставився дуже відповідально кожного року
ми починали підготовку до опалювального
сезону десь над травень в червні місяці
навіть то копії війни саме такі рішення
будуть прийняті в цьому році
хочу сказати деяку динаміку якщо
наприкінці
тижня наприкінці Минулого тижня
готовність закладів освіти до
опалювального сезону була на рівні
91%. то сьогодні це вже 94%.»
заклади освіти мають переважне право на
забезпечення теплом пане Сергію останні
тижні у нас починаються ранки
починаються з повітряних тривог саме в
цей час дітки знаходяться в школах і
скажіть будь ласка наскільки обладнані
бомбосховища чи є там тепло і наскільки
вони обладнані для того щоб проводити
навчальні навчальні процеси
знаєте Дуже дякую за запитання адже воно
сьогодні в багатьох на в багатьох на
обговоренні і я неодноразово наголошував
що безпека є на першому місці І саме
саме під час повітряних атак ми в першу
чергу ставимо в голову кута питання
безпеки дітей неодноразово під час
робочих поїздок своїх завжди відвідую
заклади освіти і завжди оцінюю е-е
роботу яка відведеться в підготовці до
бокбосховищ по
можливості тренінгу і навчання дітей до
евакуації Моя остання поїздка в регіоні
була в Тернопільській області якраз
попали ми в закладі початково в
початковій школі копали в під час
повітряної тривоги 370 дітей
організовано були
проведені до обов- до бобусховища і далі
там розпочали продовжили ті навча
вони вивчали в нормальних умовах знаєте
якщо температурний режим в укритті не
буде дозволяти
щодо санітарних норм то звісно за
рішенням педради і директора будь-які
заклади освіти може перебути перед буде
переведений на цей час на дистанційне
заняття але при цьому ніхто не буде
примушувати ні батьків ні дітей до
очного навчання перебуваючи в тих
закладах освіти наприклад там де немає
або світла або тепла станом на початок
жовтня В нас Ми провели комісійну більше
ніж 25 тисяч А об'єктів закладів освіти
огляди і на сьогодні А ми маємо
16419 закладів освіти який повністю
підготовлені до повноформатного очного
навчання що стосується шкіл то на
сьогодні 72% шкіл готові до
повноформатного або гучного навчання ви
знаєте на наступний рік ми теж в бюджеті
передбачили певну субвенцію певну
підтримку регіонів закладів освіти в
яких півтора мільярди гривень буде
закладено саме на безпекові умови і в
закладах загальної середньої освіти як
вам це зробити а що щодо очного навчання
тому що Ну от ми бачимо через постійні
обстріли є великі проблеми з постачанням
електрики на як от в цьому питанні бути
Як діткам навчатися якщо от не може
вчитель під'єднатися або Дитина можливо
порадити щось
ви знаєте всі ці рекомендації ми
постійно опрацьовуємо з директорами
департаментів освіти які проводять
семінари ми свої рекомендації дали до
кожного закладу освіти і на сьогодні
Саме основне найголовніше це бажання
навчатися і в тому числі велика роль в
під час воєнного стану набуті освіти
відіграє не тільки в школі а ще й
батьків е-е батьки сумлінні батьки Вони
мають тиждень долучитись до освітнього
процесу в цьому контексті адже звісно
буває це бувають випадки бувають
ситуації коли і вчитель не може
підключитися наявності світла але при
цьому більша частина з наших вчителів
завжди при першій можливості дають і е-е
телефонні уроки дають телефонні
завдання після того ми в будь-якому
випадку вчитель повертається до
перевірки наявності залишкових знань по
тій чи іншій темі наголошує і проводить
додаткові міні міні-годинки для
Скажімо так більшого більшого уточнення
матеріалу пойтингу матеріалу
на сьогодні окрім того ми застосували
цілу низку електронних ресурсів для того
щоб навіть під час повітряної дороги
перерваного перерваного навчання дитина
змогла повернутись до вивчення того чи
іншого навчального навчального предмету
адже це на сьогодні і електронна
бібліотека на сайті він буде
модернізації змісту освіти яка налічує
1335 підручників які повністю покривають
Всю програму навчання з першого по 11-й
клас це і
наше нашої колеги едпро які відкрили бо
без безкоштовний доступ до всіх
електронних ресурсів і підручників це і
Всеукраїнська школа онлайн яка сьогодні
містить 2500 навчальних матеріалів і ще
1 000 буде завантажено І ми в цілому
сьогодні працюємо над тим щоб ця
електронний ресурс був підключений не
тільки під час наявності
планету А ще і офлайн це такий самий є
сьогодні для 1-4 класів деніфікований
застосунок вивчаю Не чекає який працює
не тільки при наявності Інтернету А ще і
е-е працює в без без інтернету по
завантажених завданнях тобто
Міністерство сьогодні разом з
директорами департаментів разом з усіма
сміттянами дуже багато викладаємо зі
слів для того щоб освітній процес не
переривався це саме головне наше освіт
нє завдання за бажання кожен може
отримувати і далі освіту пане міністр А
зараз час осінніх канікул однак от 28%
шкіл перенесли перерву в навчанні на
зиму А які аргументи були от на користь
перенесення канікул і чи заплановані
зміни в освітньому процесі на
загальнодержавному рівні
Я дуже вам дякую за запитання адже на
сьогодні ми чітко маємо розуміти що
перше і основне основна причина як за
якою була
було перенесення освітнього канікул і
зміни в освітньому процесі Це було ну
перш за все оптимізація та економія ми
всі чітко розуміємо що Який зараз період
ми живемо в воєнний стан ми чітко
відчуваємо
загрозу російської агресії але при цьому
нині погодні умови ще є тепло і погодні
умови дозволяють продовжити навчання і
на роботу ті перерви у цьому економлячі
і тепло економічні електроенергію ми не
знаємо яка буде зима але при цьому Ми
маємо якомога більше дати нашим дітям
для безперервного освітнього процесу а
відпочинок перенести наприклад на
зимовий час де витрати електроенергії
витратити тепла є набагато більшими
рішення приймається саме закладами
освіти педагогічними радами рішення
засно батьків за консультацію з
військовими адміністраціями та органами
місцевого самоврядування Дуже дякую пане
Сергію не може вас не спитати про
студентів які навчаються за кордоном
вони призовного віку і не можуть виїхати
за кордон Скажіть будь ласка вони можуть
навчатися тільки онлайн чи є все-таки
якась альтернатива цьому навчанню
ви знаєте я ще вчора якраз таки отримав
таку уніфіковану збірку відповідей Від
міністерства закордонних справ
від своїх колег міністрів освіти країн
Європейського Союзу інших країн світу
враховуючи те що студенти чоловічої
статі з 18 до 60 років взагалі чоловік
особу чоловічої статі з 18 до 60 років в
тому числі студенти не можуть сьогодні
покинути територію України я звернувся
до своїх колег міністрів в більшості
країн світу з якими попросив щоб нашим
дітям дали можливість навчатися онлайн
або перенесли їм один рік наприклад
академічної відпустки збереження всіх
фінансових фінансових фінансових
ресурсів на наприклад наступний рік Ми
отримали комплексну відповідь на
сьогодні і дуже багато країн світу які
дали нам можливість працювати для наших
студентів і онлайн і робити або криву
навчань на наступний рік в нас підтримує
Сьогодні весь світ і наших громадян
рівень підтримки є взагалі е-е
безпрецеденти Але не всі ну є є окремі
категорії студентів які наприклад там
виїзд можливий але це короткотерміноги
наприклад якісь курси або відповідно до
міжнародних зобов'язань і міжнародних
договорів таких як І растворських як та
певні міжнародні зобов'язання України
щодо навчання наших громадян або
комплексного обміну нашими громадянами
громадянами інших країн світу такі
виїзди можливі але на короткий час таких
звернень в Міністерстві освіти дуже
багато ми всі опрацюємо кожного буде Та
на відповідь Але кожен випадок
розглядаємо індивідуально
пане Сергію я вам дуже вдячний за цю
розмову за те що ви знайшли можливість
доєднатися до нашого ефіру гарного вам
дня Це був Сергій шкарлет Міністр освіти
і науки України